olá meu nome é rodrigo e hoje eu vou
falar um pouco sobre pessoas com
necessidades especiais
eu escolhi esse tema pois quando eu
tinha seis anos e fiquei um período de
um ano e meio na cadeira de rodas
ainda bem que tive sorte de pessoas que
me ajudaram e me apoiaram
mas é também pode perceber como a vida
dessas pessoas pode ser difícil muitas
calçadas são esburacadas isso dificulta
muito a locomoção dessas pessoas o
transporte público muitas vezes não está
equipado para elas
muitos prédios ainda não têm rampas de
acesso e diz isso dificulta muito a
entrada dos cadeirantes neles inclusive
uma consulta médica que eu fui eu tive
que ser carregado pelas escadas para
chegar no consultório médico
muitas pessoas para em vagas de
deficiente acham que só cinco ou dez
minutos do tempo delas não vai fazer
diferença mas para ela que realmente
precisa vai fazer uma diferença sim
dados do ibge mostram que no brasil mais
de 1 milhão de pessoas com necessidades
especiais existem mais quentinhos
lugares onde vocês freqüentam o shopping
de escolas no trabalho quantas pessoas
com necessidades especiais ou seja
encontro muitas vezes nenhuma né
essas pessoas geralmente ficam fechadas
em casa e desenvolvem outros problemas
como a depressão e problemas se não
seria pois como podem chegar ao trabalho
essas pessoas querem ser aceitas adultos
querem trabalhar gente enche úteis
crianças querem brincar se divertir
eu sei disso pois quando eu não podia
brincar de alguma coisa ficava meio
triste
então o que podemos fazer agora vou dar
algumas dicas de como tratar essas
pessoas seja natural com ela evite
referir-se à usando termos como
inválidos ou deficientes
se você for falar com cego
então quem te abraço para ele saber como
estou conversando com ele se você for um
dia ele para algum lugar é só para ele
segurar em seu braço nunca puxei pela
bengala ou pelo braço e se você for
embora sempre disse para ele se você for
conversa por mais tempo com o cadeirante
tente manter seus olhos no mesmo nível
dele pois é incómodo para uma pessoa
ficar olhando para cima por muito tempo
você pode usar termos como correr ou
andar para com ele que vive é normal
para ele usar esses termos também nunca
secou na cadeira dele sempre no chão
pois ela quase uma extensão do seu corpo
e complementa a solubilidade na verdade
é muito mais que uma simples cadeira
para ele é incorreta a utilização do
termo um surdo-mudo pois muitos surdos
sabe falar e os que não sabem fazer em
linguagem de sinais
toquinho seu braço para ele saber que
você está conversando com eles não ele
não vai saber e sempre mantenha seu
lábio visível pois vários deles sabem
fazer leitura labial
nunca subestime uma pessoa com alguma
deficiência intelectual pois elas são
capazes de muitas coisas
o site se for necessário ou se ela pedir
resumindo não precisamos melhorar é a
questão da mobilidade para essas pessoas
como também precisamos incluí las no
nosso dia a dia
essa foi minha apresentação espero que
tenham gostado